В інтерв'ю німецькому виданню Focus
президент України Петро Порошенко заявив, що він
за останніх чотири роки продемонстрував, що жоден олігарх
не може розраховувати на привілеї.
Утім цього твердження не поділяє жоден з опитаних DW експертів.
Політтехнолог Тарас Березовець вважає, що деолігархізація
відбувається лише частково і щодо груп, які нелояльні до президента.
А за словами експерта з питань енергетики Михайла Гончара,
олігархам цілком успішно вдається зберегти статус кво
навіть попри реформи за європейським взірцем.
Впродовж останніх років прийняті
базові закони, наприклад,
в сфері енергетики,
які відтворюють Європейське енергетичне законодавство в Україні,
Все робиться для того,
щоб зберегти під новою європейською
обгорткою старий олігархічний порядок.
Реформи європейського взірця передбачають
передусім демонтаж олігархічної системи.
За словами Василя Юрчишина, експерта з економіки,
орупція в Україні залишається на надто високому рівні,
щоб можна було втішатися, що ніхто не має жодних привілеїв.
Якби рівень корупції реально зменшувався,
був би меншим і вплив олігархів,
переконаний адвокат Володимир Богатир.
Безперечно така форма правління,
яка дає можливість поєднувати
приватний капітал з державними можливостями,
з державною владою –
вона є неприйнятною для України.
Українські олігархи не виготовляють унікальної, інноваційної продукції,
яка би створювала конкуренцію на міжнародному ринку,
наголошує Дарина Каленюк з Центру протидії Корупції.
Натомість вони наживаються на державних ресурсах,
отримують державні бюджетні дотації і просувають закони,
які усувають конкуренцію.
Разом з тим під тиском міжнародних партнерів України
створені незручні для олігархів органи.
Зараз створений орган- НАБУ
який здатен побороти це статус кво
і зробити проблеми олігархам.
Якби Петро Олексійович був щирий у тому щоб створити проблеми олігархам,
він би не ставив палки в колеса НАБУ.
Він би не намагався вже другий рік
просунути ручного аудитора, який
змінить незалежного директора Бюро.
Він би не блокував створення Антикорупційного Суду,
і в нас би вже антикорупційні судді розглядали справи НАБУ.
Тож, щоб реально позбавити олігархів привілеїв,
в Україні зроблено далеко не все.
І навряд чи це вдасться президенту-бізнесмену,
вважають українські експерти.